[Applause]
all right you get to ask me to do
anything or ask me to tell you the truth
about anything and we have jen gildow
here so what's it gonna be
okay or dare it's going to be a dare oh
so i'm here with my friend victoria and
our friend kelly was supposed to come
with us but she's actually studying for
finals and you're literally like her
favorite celebrity so i want to ask you
if you'd mind facetiming her of course
give me
[Applause]
i hope she picked up
we'll see if we are we oh hi
[Applause]
welcome to the show kelly we're so
bummed that you can't be here
wait okay so what are you doing right
now
i'm just studying for my finals oh wait
what
how's it going what are you feeling the
most confident in and what do you think
you need to study more
oh um
so i have a final critique for my art
project tomorrow but i have to study for
my history class like it's not going
well okay well literally just study as
if your life depends on it
and then tomorrow you can kick back
and the best time to rest is when you
know you crushed it as hard as you could
[Applause]
and
may i please send you a ticket to come
to the show as soon as you're done
studying
your friend jen is a really good friend
and look there's your other friend so we
have an invitation and a ticket waiting
for you as soon as you're done studying
[Applause]
all right i'll see you soon
thank you jen so much all right that's
it that's all the time
thank you for choosing to spend your
time with us i make this show for you
so take it with you
[Music]
you